for artemiev with only a draw magnus
carlsen will be ready for the final in
the air things masters and now we're
jumping into game three between yana
pomniacci and andre yasipenko jana
pomnyacci is up by one point after
winning game two and if he wins this one
it's gonna be over he will be ready for
the final look at the bar you guys yeah
it's on white side this opening was
another italian game that we saw in an
earlier clash between these two but this
one i think has gone wrong for black
look at the black king it's just too
airy it's too open white's queen is
about to zoom along a diagonal and go
towards that black king if you compare
it to white's king
at least for now relatively safe the
white king yes black has this bishop on
a great diagonal but
i don't think you're going to break
through there so it's looking good for
white black is a pawn up however and if
black can survive the storm maybe some
chances
i would love to say to yan you're
supposed to sit in those chairs not
laying them
it's not a bed it's a chair yeah
can we do that how far can you go i'm
not going to try because it will go
wrong and then we'll fall back
oh wow it's very bendy it's quite bendy
this could go hot but it's actually and
it's very you can like shoot up yeah
okay
anyways but that's just how much jan
loves this position he's so relaxed
because he knows he's still in control
but it might be quite an instructive
thing actually to kind of lean i'm kind
of mean it's an all seriousness to lean
back because you know sometimes when
you're calculating you get so lost and
everything if you lean back you can kind
of see the position bigger fresh
bigger picture yeah it was it was great
wasn't it alexander grisjick the
candidates when he was playing everyone
else had these really comfy chairs and
uh he had this really like really
uncomfy chair and he said i don't want
to comfy checks i don't want to fall
asleep i want to be uncomfy so i stay
awake and that was his thing so it's
actually like similar similar idea stay
awake uh by being uncomfy
interesting interesting kind of stats
you know yeah should you have
comfortable chairs do you i mean i can't
i don't think i've ever paid attention
to my chairs no not really the same here
but i mean uh i think i'd like to have a
bit of comfiness in my life
there's an article in chess 24 right now
as well about chairs and the comfortable
uh the levels of comfort and yeah what
each player should want uh i do the same
though but with food i have to be
slightly hungry when i play otherwise i
just can't play chess if i'm full i just
can't focus bloated
yeah i have to remember that one next
time play
you out for a steak meal i mean if
you're treating me to the food then i'll
take it but uh okay
the hunger makes me play quicker and
more urgently and uh just makes me more
focused it's sort of a tactic against
david you know because we're
you know he's a strong player and it's
unlikely that we're ever going to beat
him maybe we can take something like
some really delicious smelling food
because he's a bit hungry
i mean i've had that before when my
opponent
whipped out a really
messy kebab in front of me
and i'm just like you can't eat that in
front of me because it's just everything
all over the pieces oh no i couldn't do
that to david
whip out a kebab in front of him and
just start eating it no
i had someone do that with me with a
burger
but uh yeah let's i think uh there has
been a move meanwhile andre isapenko
down on the clock down to six minutes
has just brought his rook into the game
that rook was doing nothing in the
corner so he's swung it across very
sensible however white has a strong
response here and i'm assuming jan is
going to play it once he gets back to
his chair uh he's going to bring the
white queen out there's two juicy
squares two choices here for the white
queen but uh they look good let's just
explain why white is doing well despite
being upon down simon which queen's
square would you use this one to pin the
black knight or even this one hitting
the one uh hitting the black knight and
hoping to go maybe later for some
checkmate ideas i i don't know i mean
i'd probably tried the one you put on
the board that h5 just because uh
if i can get rid of your knight then
then it's game over uh but they they
both look extremely tempting
in the position just get the queen into
the attack and uh build up uh the the
with your pieces so yeah and i think
black either way no matter where white
plants the cr the queen will have to
retreat his own queen as a defender
where she saw this this theme uh earlier
between these two and actually this has
been played so black's queen is most
likely going to have to step back there
are some tricks in the position for
example is what you can't get greedy and
take this pawn because the black knight
will suddenly jump forward with a nasty
check a fork and it cannot be captured
because of a pin the black queen pinning
this pawn towards the white king so
there are still some traps in the
position but then again okay this has
been played but then again at some point
white could think about just being
greedy taking this pawn hitting the
black rook at some point you might even
try and swing this rook into the game
bring it across the long way what about
what about king f i'd love to use my
f-born here because your your knight is
the black knight is kind of supporting
black's position it seems so if i can
again it's looking at key defenders in
your opposition is it's a good tactic to
use that knight very good defender get
rid of the knight how do i do that i use
the pawn my pawns pinned get my king out
of the way then use the pawn so
something like that as well could could
be an idea i mean it's very nice
get out of this diagonal and i was going
to ask another question because it is
tempting here
to capture a pawn with a knight for
instance
could you do that do a little hit and
run come back and then maybe start using
kind of switched tactics kind of instead
of playing so aggressively just kind of
go well i'm going to improve my work on
the queen side
yeah yeah and hit some pawns with your
rook bring that piece into the game you
could at the very least just retreat
your knight and then combine it with
simon's idea of stepping the king across
for example if black just makes a move
now you move your king across and the
idea is to push this pawn forward to
destabilize the knight but here it would
also be a double attack so extra
effective
i like both of those moves to be honest
i think
maybe moving the king out the way but
then this would allow a pawn to kick
away this white knight
um so first move i would calculate at
least here would be a capture just to
see whether we can get away with any
greed so
to take this pawn or not to take the
spawn that is the current question
yes it makes sense to take it just to
secure your knight in the middle but
okay he's playing for your move simon
the ginger gm school of chess yeah it's
always worrying
look at the evaluation bar just drop as
soon as he plays it
but there's definitely logic behind it
right it's the human touch yeah
top move okay the top move was actually
um a different move moving the rook one
square to the b1 which looks so strange
doesn't it but yeah i mean it makes a
lot of sense that rook move but it
as humans we're trying to look at the
one side of the board right where the
kings are i guess here you just have to
calculate c6 f4 and if you think this
works very well as white then
then you play it i mean maybe not even
f4 but it's pretty uh
it's pretty sort of if it works it wins
uh is is why maybe jan jan has played it
so meeting an attack on the white knight
maybe with a counter attack against the
black knight maybe i mean yeah it's a
lot to calculate right but at the very
minimum white could even retreat the
night and still this idea that you
mentioned yeah coming a bit later so
very very tense i think black has to
play that move what else i can't see any
other move at all i mean uh how much
time does he have vk has under four
minutes sap encounters reminded one if
he loses this game then he's out yeah so
he's under a serious uh amount of
pressure here and yan yan loves
attacking like this doesn't he his is
you know
why he was a challenger for the world
championships it's a pity we didn't
really get more these positions for yan
well not not a plea for magnus but you
know pity for everyone else in the world
championships yeah you know this is when
we see him do it he does it so well uh
generally and this is embracing his own
style but at the world championship uh
it felt like he was trying to play a
different style yeah or it felt like he
was playing with the handbrake on yes
just he couldn't get moving really
couldn't get into fourth fifth gear yeah
and i think that was a great skill that
magnus actually achieved he stopped him
getting his car into gear really he
stopped getting busy he didn't allow
positions like this which is a great
skill in itself controlling the game
um
maybe the other idea this king move is
actually just go uh bring the knight to
f4 take the pawn of your queen bring the
knight in you know you can just play it
a bit simpler as well put the knight on
that square rather than the pawn yeah
maybe we show this because that's very
okay we're going to see it actually on
the board but uh the pawn hitting the
knight the knight has retreated and now
uh as you mentioned simon if black just
makes a move then queen takes pawn is
possible because this knight check is
not working anymore firstly it's not
czech and also the white king no longer
on the same line as the black queen
and this is deadly now the white knight
joining the attack yeah uh ivanka taught
me that three is the magic number these
are three attacking pieces ready to go
towards the black king that looks really
nice it is really nice and uh i just
really feel sorry for black's king it
really needs some pawns behind it in
front of it rather
um
so do you kind of disagree with the bar
right now should it be
you know more fit in favor of beyond
possibly maybe there's a genius defense
that the computer will find but for
humans it's so unpleasant and also it's
the type of advantage right now 0.4
which
if black is not accurate might just
explode into plus five plus six for
white so
it's not the type it's going to be long
term i really don't think there is a
defense because i'm just you know take a
look at every single one of uh black's
pieces
the rooks can't move okay well essepenko
is trying he's breaking forward in the
center
okay very logical i mean there we go the
evaluation bar does shoot up though just
like you said david yeah literally i
mean
i mean
even pushing white's pawn forward is
getting that little unit as an idea but
the simple idea queen takes pawn pawn
takes pawn actually yeah
too many good moves and yan doesn't even
think about which one to play
so the problem is black's queen's tied
down it can't go on on any counter
attack because it has to stop
checkmating ideas against its own king
and still this idea of blacks of the
white queen stepping back taking a pawn
was deadly almost and there's just no
coordination whatsoever from any of
black's pieces
well white white's soon going to be a
pawn up with the attack which is which
is quite a nice position to be in i mean
you know what else do you want in life i
hadn't had a funny expression from the
russians okay white is a porn up and as
compensation has an attack and
pawn up with compensation yes
okay so black trying to kick away the
white knight now black's bishop was on a
great diagonal but there was nothing
actually to do that and
okay napoli actually making a bit of a
face as he retreats and takes this pawn
with the queen we were advocating this
but now at least black can get rid of
the white knight which was a potential
attacker
and no immediate checkmates one thing
that does worry me a little bit about
napoleon is how he's playing the move so
quickly because you know while we've
seen him have great instincts he has
missed opportunities because of this
yeah sometimes not looking for all the
options and okay we do see the black
bishop trade itself off for white knight
and black recapturing a pawn in the
center so it's actually level material
right now white is still doing great
because black's king is the more
vulnerable of the two and also white's
rooks are combining very well black has
a lot of weak pawns
but then again i would be happier now
the bishops uh now the white knight is
off the board
at least the queen and knight they can
team up uh if the scenario is right
the problem though is the king the black
king you know you can just see a
scenario where you know a set of rooks
come off and white lifts the rook up to
the third row and then
i don't see any defense for for black
whatsoever i'm having a hard time with
my beginner level to understand why the
black king is so unsafe i see two strong
rooks next to it i see a queen in front
of it
why is it so unsafe
that's a great question kai uh maybe if
we pull up the board we can show this
it's simply because the number of pawns
in front of it so white's king is super
safe it has two pawns to hide behind
that means the white pieces are free to
roam and do anything they want the pawns
will act as the defenders whereas uh if
we the black rooks are great defending
the back rank at least but in terms of
any vertical attacks against the back
king the knight has to stay here pretty
much the queen has to stay in front of
it so these pieces they're just stuck
and paralyzed uh they're
okay at least they have to stay near the
black king so i do like this last move
by isapenko maybe creating some tension
here with a pin also an escape square
for his king but in general these pieces
are stuck as defenders white's pieces
are just free to do anything because
black only has one pawn as a defender
white has two pawns as the shelter so
look at this another pin created and uh
this is the point i think uh here kaia
look at this at just a pin and black's
king is weak from the front
and uh okay black's queen has to step
back breaking that pin we see a trade of
rooks and white has gobbled up a pawn
uh at some point white would love to i
just want to create some space to run
away with the white king just before it
gets checkmated but okay the evaluation
bar surprisingly going in favor
maybe an amazing idea here yeah i mean
you can try to check mate white oh wow
so uh why not how would you do this
simon queen h6 even okay and just uh you
know if he finds this move because uh
you've always got you've always got to
look at okay it's very hard to turn from
defensive to attacking it's one of the
hardest things but you know the white
king is is is a little bit funny there
and you've always got to look at
creating some threats and
that that move is is actually very hard
how do you defend against that movie
yeah suddenly things could be turning
because look at stockfish it has three
suggestions there two of them give white
a big advantage but black does have this
resource bringing the queen round and as
simon says this is actually hard to deal
with because this is a direct
checkmating threat this move would trap
the white king
on its back rank behind its own pawns
a lot of work to be done here will he
find this move i mean he's got 40
seconds espienko and it doesn't look
like he's found it yet just from his
body language yeah i think he's just not
changing from defense to attack as you
mentioned what does white do after this
move i mean he hasn't defined it he
hasn't found it no this would have
required white to i think look at this
move wow okay nice let's uh okay i was
going to say let's go back to the
players but right now white has
sacrificed the queen if the rook takes
this is a deadly check white is about to
emerge with an extra bishop let's go
back to the players we'll explain this
later but white is about to win i think
he has one yeah instafranco gives up
he's about to lose a whole piece for
free napoli actually perfect technique
to finish it off wow this semi-final
match is over after three games
janupomnyachi winning game two